seems like every few months for the last
ten years I've been doing this story but
every time it's actually a story based
on new data based on the latest data and
once again April of 2018 last month was
the four hundredths consecutive kind of
hard to say that four hundred
consecutive month with above-average
temperatures
four hundred months is of course more
than 33 years December of 1984 was the
last time that the earth had a cooler
than average month this probably is not
going to shock many people in our
audience but climate scientists say that
the cause of those three decades of
warmer than average temperatures is
climate change due to human activity on
our planet
particularly the burning of fossil fuels
yeah it's not really surprising to most
people in our audience we now have as a
species enough temperature data where we
can do these rolling thirty-year
averages and really track weather a
couple of warm winters are outliers or
are they part of a trend and the trend
is very clear and it's not good and
Argentina of all places had the warmest
April on record going back to the first
time they tracked this in 1961 57 years
one other note because I know that I'm
gonna get emails about this we're
talking about global temperatures there
are climate sceptics that live in the US
and they are just feverishly pointing
out that April was cooler than average
in the United States and that's true I
mean here in Boston it was basically
still winter for most of April 2.2
degrees below average temperature but
that actually is important for different
reasons than the skeptics think it's
important number one what matters is
global temperature and number two any
serious climate change model accounts
for more extreme temperatures so
worldwide we had the four hundredth
straight warmer than average month in
the US we had the coldest April in 21
years which is exactly in line with what
the climate models say many high and low
record high and low temperatures
unusually warm and unusually cold
weather and we've talked about this
before but climate sign
deniers will often say David looking at
20 or 30 or even a hundred years of
temperatures it's too short a time span
to really tell us anything about the
long-term temperature trends but the
truth is we don't have just temperature
data we have for example carbon dioxide
data which we can look at much further
back into history there's currently more
co2 in the atmosphere than at any time
in the last 800,000 years and this is
one of those meta issues in the
political world I've often talked about
you know if you care about education or
you care about gay marriage be care
about income inequality there are these
sort of meta issues that impact our
ability as humans to deal with your
issue right campaign finance is a meta
issue media ownership and net neutrality
are meta issues our economic system at
large is a meta issue free speech is a
meta issue we really need to add climate
change to that right because if we
destroy our planet if our focus becomes
running away from the coasts which are
increasingly underwater and dealing with
climate change things like finance are
gonna stop mattering pretty quickly if
we make our planet uninhabitable for our
children media coverage of LGBT rights
is sadly very quickly going to become
irrelevant so I think it's important to
really think about what we're saying
warmer than average temperatures dating
back to December of 84 France and B then
USSR were doing nuclear tests and it was
the Cold War when we had a colder than
average month on our planet
III I'm sort of at a loss pad as to how
to even communicate the gravity of the
problem yet people I feel like I want to
chime in and say something here but it's
not even like it's news because this is
just the new realities I don't know what
to say we do this story every three
months last month was once again the
such-and-such consecutive month of
warmer than average temperatures I was
nine months old the last time we had a
colder than average month think about
that right I was living in Argentina
nine months old I lived there five years
I moved to the United States I went to
elementary school all this time every
single month warmer than
Ridge temperature I go to high school I
go to college I start the David Pakman
show every month warmer than average
temperature warmer than average
temperature it keeps going and then we
get to May of 2018 where now I tell you
yeah the streak continues uninterrupted
last month was the 400th consecutive 400
consecutive 400th why do I struggle with
that gonna work on 100 consecutive
warmer than average month of global
temperature if these were random results
and not part of a trend merely by chance
alone there should have been some cooler
than average months at some point since
I was 9 months old and we're moving
backwards on this issue under our
current administration truly immoral and
I think Pat said it best what else can
we say there's really nothing surprising
here in this data send me your thoughts
on reddit we have a subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT quick break
back after this today's program is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses which I now have two pairs of
Warby Parker offers a free five day
in-home trial of their glasses you try
five pairs you see which you like I wear
contact lenses on the show but I often
wear glasses at night and on weekends
and both of my pairs of Warby Parker
glasses are great I did the free at-home
trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just 95
dollars that's what mine cost to try the
five pairs and support the David Pakman
show
go to war V Parker trial comm /t DPS